she was a cultural icon a national
treasure and our forever golden girl
welcome to et remembers betty white we
were all so excited to celebrate her
100th birthday which was just 17 days
away you know we dedicated the entire
show to betty on friday but we've got
even more memories in our e.t vault to
share as we learn new details about
betty's final days
[Music]
you are a woman who loves to work what
is it that makes you want to come to
work every single day oh i just love i'm
so lucky to be in this business i never
take it for granted
you are the most remarkable woman in the
business
who
no
i'm the luckiest old brother in the
business
e.t checked in with betty just two weeks
ago she was upbeat feeling good and
amazed by the idea of turning 100. this
was the last time she was spotted out in
public betty was all smiles running
errands in january of 2020 the day
before her 98th birthday as for her
final days will betty had been keeping
it low-key during the pandemic e.t spoke
with two of her confidants jeff witches
her longtime friend and agent and
producer steve batcher who was working
with betty on a new documentary she
actually passed away at home and you
know i think she was just living her
best life and that's what we want for
betty white she was basically healthy i
was over there at the house a number of
times
and we enjoyed playing gin rummy
together
now i will say her mind was sharp
a rumor was that she didn't want to be
in la in her brentwood home she wanted
to be in carmel at the home she built
with her late husband if betty white
wanted to go to carmel she would go to
carmel i mean she was in control of her
life she was very comfortable
just last month betty told et our show
felt like home to her and our interviews
like a visit with a good friend are you
ever going to retire no of course not i
don't think so why
you work for the things you really
believe in
this was our last sit down with betty in
2017 she was 95 years young at the time
what is the secret to your longevity
blessed with good health
really good health i love a cocktail i
love i love
peanut butter and jelly and stuff but i
don't abuse
the things that that i know if if you're
blessed with this good health you should
take advantage of it
another life secret betty said quote see
the funny side not the downside i get
bored with people that complain it's
such a waste of time
batcher last saw betty in late december
he was helping her film a shout out to
her fans for betty white a celebration
it's the last video she did 10 days
before she passed away she wanted to
thank her fans sincerely from the bottom
of her heart
and while her beloved fans may have
feared her passing betty was not afraid
of dying it's lovely to think
there is something we don't know
and
as as a human race we have learned so
much and we've gained so much knowledge
but that's something
nobody knows what happens afterwards
it's a secret
you know i first came to et they sent me
to interview betty and i was like ooh i
better talk loud and slowly
uh no
betty was smart as a whip quick so quick
she got you guys oh she got me together
i was a little nervous because i was
like she's a little bit faster than
nothing now betty was also considered a
barrier breaker too indeed she was she
continues to hold the guinness book of
world records for the entertainer with
the longest tv career yes of all time
and you know that career spanned eight
decades
betty was born in 1922 sliced bread was
invented in 1928 so you could say betty
truly was the greatest thing since
sliced bread
betty started working in radio right
after graduating from high school and
then hollywood came calling i started
back in 1949
and i was on a daytime talk show five
and a half hours a day six days a week
live when she co-hosted the variety
series hollywood on television the show
was criticized for featuring black tap
dancer arthur duncan betty stood up and
responded quote i'm sorry live with it
and gave duncan more air time well i
might have known neither one of us could
pass that little old lady with a basket
full of puppies in 1952 betty headlined
her first tv sitcom life with elizabeth
and was one of hollywood's first female
producers she also received her very
first emmy nod for her acting on the
show is that so she would go on to earn
a total of 21 nominations and five emmy
wins she won her first two for playing
sue ann nevins on the mayor tyler moore
show turned my career around suanne came
in you know and just caused a little
habit spies things are mysterious
thieves things that are undercover
sneaky
and when she wasn't acting betty just
loved appearing on game shows i like it
because it's mental exercise i think
instead of just sitting there
blurry-eyed watching something else
happen you can't resist a game show if
you're a game player at all she would
garner an entire new generation of fans
as ditzy rosen island in the golden
girls and also appeared in the
short-lived spin-off the golden palace
with rue mcclanahan and estelle getty
it's amazing
it i have not seen chemistry like this
work well frankly since the four golden
girls got together betty just loved
making audiences laugh and even tried
out dramedy guest starring on allie
mcbeal as ally's psychotherapist we had
the best time calista is really some
piece of talent
in the 2000s betty continued to break
barriers and relish in new challenges
how lucky can you get so
do i get the job i've got a recurring
role on on boston legal that i i think
that's another dream that i didn't
expect betty flexed her dramatic skills
playing james spader's secretary from
2005 through 2008. during that time she
also guest starred on the bold and the
beautiful i'm sorry for everything soap
opera is completely different to
anything i've ever done before is i
grandma annie
in 2009 the then 87 year old cemented
her career resurgence with this
scene-stealing role in the proposal
let's see if we can find your boobs
they're in there somewhere oh my god
she's a national treasure i mean i we
don't have enough time for me to
to spew enough love for betty white ryan
reynolds paid tribute to his on-screen
grandma tweeting quote the world looks
different now in a statement to e.t
sandra bullock says quote i'll have to
buy some rose-colored glasses because
betty was that for all of us sandra they
never made one like sandra talented
beautiful funny the pair stayed close
and when sandy presented betty with a
life achievement on her at the sag
awards betty roasted her as only betty
could isn't it
heartening to see how far a girl as
plain as she is can go
she also went viral in 2010 thanks to
this classic super bowl snickers ad
you're playing like betty white out
there that's not what your girlfriend
said
today at the at the function
the waitress bought me a plate with a
snickers bar
i'm here tonight because you wanted me
to be
that same year at the age of 88 betty
became the oldest person ever to host
snl she got the gig after fans
campaigned for her on facebook i didn't
know what facebook was
and now that i do know what it is it
sounds like a huge waste of time
she's america's sweetheart still and
she's a comic genius she won her fifth
primetime emmy for that episode a month
after snl her sitcom with valerie
bertinelli hot in cleveland premiered so
what are you like a hundred
i don't like you
all of a sudden things kind of exploded
and i'm just riding the wave and having
a wonderful time
and 2018 marked betty's final tv
appearance she got a standing ovation
while honored at the emmys it's
incredible that i'm still in this
business that i'm still
and you are still putting up with me
you